[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Heather
starts this hour in Tampa Florida hi
Heather how are
you well I'm better than I deserve good
for you I love it how can we
help yes um so I'm just trying to come
up with a good investment plan um both
my husband and I we've been married now
20 years this month and um I'm always
just trying to look for better
opportunities to try to keep um you know
uh investment up and while we still kind
of work you know job to job we kind of
work paycheck to paycheck and so um I
have a Apple stock that I invested in
many years ago and I have a good wealth
since we've been in Apple stock we've
tripled since we started and um we also
have two rothar IRAs each just only
6,000 for him 800 ,000 for me and um we
got about $220,000 in savings and so I
was trying to figure out I also do have
just um a house that we just bought um
and so we're paying on that and two cars
is what we have uh no other debts just
those things and so I was trying to
figure out in my mind what I could do
with my savings instead of making it so
unproductive just sitting in the account
you know I have only $20,000 in savings
but would it be best to pay off a car
would it be best um to uh cash out the
Apple stock because you know of concerns
they always say around election time
specifically with crash they always talk
about that happening so I'm just trying
to get a better idea because I spoke
with my financial advisor and he
suggested maybe money market funds and
I'm not very wise as far as
financially
okay um money market funds for the
20,000 yeah he wasn't saying the full
20,000 he was like you could start out
putting 10,000 in money market funds
which like I said I'm not very familiar
with it yeah well money market fund is a
fancy savings account it doesn't pay
much pays more than a bad savings
account at a bank it's basically a high
yield savings accounts what it is so um
but still not paying big money now
here's the thing
what we teach Heather is that your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income okay your income right now is
going to two car payments if you had
those car payments going into
Investments every month you would be
Building Wealth pretty
rapidly so our first goal is going to be
to clear those car payments what do you
owe on your
cars so um it's about uh 16,000 and 18
,000 wow okay and you've only got 20
what's your household income right uh my
household income is about a little over
a 100,000 good okay a year all right so
if I woke up in your shoes we teach a
process to get you to wealth by getting
you out of debt called the baby steps
baby step one is $1,000 in the bank now
how much do you have an Apple stock what
is it valued at today if you cash it in
21,000 excellent okay all right this is
going to jar your system can you hold on
to your chair for a second because I'm
getting ready to knock you out of the
chair okay here we go you you ready for
the ride Ready set go here we go you
ready oh my just be be kind I'm going to
be kind but it's going to scare the crap
out of you are you ready I'm cashing in
the Apple stock and the 20,000 and
paying off my cars
today
wow can you
breathe
well of course I mean now that would be
stupid if you don't do the next
thing and the next thing is your first
thing you got to do now is rebuild your
emergency fund which is what that 20,000
is it's not supposed to make any money
it's supposed to sit there and keep life
off of your head cuz life's going to
come and land on your head and you w't e
a helmet and that's what the 20,000
bucks is it's the umbrella in the rain
cuz some days it rains so you need a
rainy day fund that's your 20,000 it's
not supposed to be making you a bunch of
money but right now we're paying off a
car with it so it doesn't matter so the
cars are gone any money that we don't
have in retirement account than and
you'll have 7,000 left after that
yeah start your emergency F start your
emergency fund I do want to set that
over in a money market or a high yield
and I want you to get about 20,000 back
in there that's your 3 to six months of
expenses that's baby step three now you
don't have any payments and you've got
that so now we've got to start investing
which is 15% of your income that'd be
$155,000 a year 1,00 bucks a month going
in your company 401ks with a match in
good mutual funds or sit down with your
broker or get a new one and sit down and
get your uh your Roth IRA going into
good mutual funds which'll be easy
hether because there's no car payment to
to your point earlier yep then you freed
up so much income do you know what me
month-to month hether and so those Roth
IRAs that have six in one and eight in
the other you're going to start seeing
lots of traction in that and it's yeah
you start adding $1,000 $1,500 a month
to your retirement plan that's $15
$18,000 a year making a hundred grand
then um and if you got a match at work
and these mutual funds go up this year
it would have made a little over 10%
this year year to date if you put it in
January 1 to right now you would have
made 10% on good mutual funds and
whoever's talking talking to you about a
stock market crash quit listening to
those fools okay stock market's not
going to crash it goes up and it goes
down goes up and it goes down election
time it is always crazy there's always
been stupid people in Washington of both
Brands and there's still stupid people
in Washington of both Brands some right
now some of them are more stupid than
normal but there're stupid people in
Washington okay so that's never that's
not a new that's not new information no
but to her Point election time people do
like things do kind of stall out people
hold they watch they see the stock
market doesn't crash on Election it
doesn't no it doesn't crash but you're
going to see a little bit of that
volatility and that's normal you can go
back to basically every election year
every four years and you see the same
thing so it doesn't mean it's going to
crash but goes up it goes down and
you're in the right you're in the right
of it all so you just right you're just
dumping 1,00 bucks 1,200 bucks a month
1,400 bucks a month every single month
automatically out of your check into
your 401K with a match or into Roth IRAs
and Heather and I think Heather you're
you're a prime example that so many
people experience with their money
honestly you're trying to do like five
different things you got a single stock
here you're trying to do some retirement
you got car payments you have a little
bit of money here savings and it's like
I you feel so scattered versus clearing
it all out and saying boom boom boom
boom boom and then you can now tomorrow
or after the emergency funds fully
funded after that 7,000 you can fully
focus on retirement you have one thing
to do at a time and that's what gives
you power and less of this like bizarre
feeling that you probably feel with your
money yeah if you pay off the cars and
have 7,000 left over today by by the end
of the year you'll have your 20,000 and
in January you'll start saving 15% from
this point forward of your income going
into retirement you'll retire wealthy if
you'll do those things but you got to be
on a budget to do it you got to be in
agreement with your husband and no more
borrowing on stupid cars stop it